ما زالت اصوات المتظاهرين تصدح في مختلف
المدن الايرانيه رغم انحسارها بسبب
الحمالات القمعيه للسلطات الايرانيه مرت
اربعه اشهر على اندلاع التظاهرات ولا يزال
المتظاهرون مصرين على ايصال صوتهم متحدين
كل العقبات التي تواجههم والتهديد الذي
يتربص به عقوبات اعدام وحمالات اعتقال
وملاحقات في المستشفيات والكليات وفي
غيرها كلها عقيل واجهه المتظاهرين ولا
تزال حملات القمه التي قامت بها الاجهزه
الامنيه الايرانيه دفعت المتظاهرين الى
تطوير اساليب جديده للتعبير عن مواقفهم
حيث اخذت الاحتجاجات واشكالا جديده
كالاضرابات وكتابه الشعارات لتصلها الى
احراق صور المرشد
وما يعكس الصعوبات التي واجهها المتظاهرون
على امتداد الاشهر الاربعه الماضيه
الارقام التي رصدتها المنظمات الحقوقيه
غير الحكوميه والتي كشفت عن قتل
481 شخصا على الاقل في صفوف المتظاهرين
هذا فضلا عن مواجهه ما لا يقل عن 109
اشخاص عن مواجهتهم عقوبه الاعدام في قضايا
تتعلقوا بالاحتجاجات وفقا لهذه المنظمات
الحقوقيه غير الحكوميه اذن كما تم اعدامه
اربعه اشخاص لحد الان في قضايا لها صله
بالتظاهرات
[موسيقى]
قصه الفتاه الايرانيه مساء مين التي اشعلت
شراره اطول موجه احتجاجه بدات بعد
اعتقالها على يد الشرطه الاخلاق ووفاتها
في 16 من سبتمبر الماضي
150 مدينه ايرانيه حسب المعارضه على مدار
لاسباب الصحيه
لضربه على الراس
التظاهرات جميلات اضرابات لقطاعات عده
ابرزها قطع النفط في الذكرى الاربعين
لوفاه ماسه ومع المتظاهرون بعنف او الى
ديسمبر الماضي لاحتواء الاحتجاجات صدر
قرار بحل شرطه الاخلاق